you've done so many action films and you
were famous for always giving it
everything you have for each film almost
like you're going to go all the way for
each movie is that true yes because I
don't know especially fact I don't know
computer I just risked my life to do
films what can we do it
John job so yes so even if you think you
might get seriously hurt you still do it
anyway I never think I would get hurt I
thought it would never happen in my in
me yeah but I wanna tell you I just get
hurt get hurt Jackie you'd think after a
while you'd start to consider the
possibility that you might get hurt yeah
if you've been hurt fifty times so many
times I remember I remember long time
probably you hear this story first time
I met Steven Spielberg Wow Steven
Spielberg yes why should I say you know
open the doors hi how are you let me
find the word to say something oh can I
ask you a question how can you make a
movie with a human moving camera with
dinosaur together yeah for me I just we
lock the camera we can put the dinosaur
the human then we put a camera - that's
easy right but move yeah this is so
difficult
I said he's that easy Jackie just punch
punch then okay can I ask you a question
I said yes how can you from this
building jump disappear I said more easy
rolling camera action jump Hospital
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you